[Musik]
hallo ihr lieben heute zeige ich euch
meine kinder country torte und zwar habe
ich mir die schon seit jahren genau so
vorgestellt jetzt habe ich endlich
geschafft sie zu backen und wie schmeckt
genauso wie in meinen vorstellungen
mir war es ganz wichtig dass wir in
unserer torte nicht so viel teig haben
und viel mehr von den extremen
und genau deshalb habe ich auch nur zwei
schichten gemacht ich habe den teig
schon in einem separaten video gezeigt
ich habe allerdings die menge ein wenig
verringert und backen sie jetzt in
meinem eckigen back rahmen mit den maßen
20 x 40 cm und wenn ihr das rezept noch
mal das gewinnen wollt verlinkt ich es
euch auf jeden fall in die infobox
nach nur zwölf minuten im ofen ist der
teig dann auch schon fertig und muss
vollständig abkühlen und für meine
geht's weiter mit der leckeren creme
wir benötigen 500 gramm mascarpone 1
esslöffel vanille exakt bei 100 gramm
geschmolzene weiße kuvertüre die habe
ich bereits abkühlen lassen 300 gramm
kalte schlagsahne drei teelöffel
donnerstag für die sahne und 60 gramm
kellogg's smacks ich habe allerdings den
markt genommen die schmeckt genau gleich
und ich bin ja ein fan von schnellen
creme füllungen und deswegen machen wir
das jetzt auch super schnell und einfach
als erstes wird die sahne steif
geschlagen
die verschlagen besitzt ca 30 sekunden
an geben dann das bonaparte mit hinzu
und lassen das dann komplett steif
schlagen
[Musik]
die samen lager ich dann bis zur
weiterverarbeitung im kühlschrank auch
wenn das nur ein paar minuten sind und
weiter geht's mit der mascarpone wie
gebe ich zusammen mit der geschmolzenen
kuvertüre und dem vanille extrakt in
eine schüssel und wichtig ist dass die
geschmolzene kuvertüre wirklich komplett
abgekühlt ist also 15 minuten reichen
dafür kommen auch hier soll er auch
nicht wieder aus herten
aber bitte nicht weitermachen solange
sie noch warm ist damit die mascarpone
nicht gewinnt nachdem das ganze dann zu
einer masse gemixt wurde geben wir die
saale mit hinzu und heben die mit einem
teich aber unter ganz zum schluss geben
wir dann die cerealien mit hinzu und auf
die würde ich nicht verzichten denn dann
hat man erst dieses kinder country
feeling und die creme schmeckt meiner
meinung nach genauso wie im kindergarten
wales mein tortenboden der inzwischen
komplett ausgekühlt ist dufry ich kurz
von backwaren und anschließen müssen
genau in der mitte durch teilen damit
mit zwei bühnen erhalten
meinen ersten tortenboden gebe ich dann
auch meine serviert hatte und hier habe
ich noch die kleinen hummel ausgebessert
wer mag kann da jetzt noch ein paar bot
papierstreifen unterlegen falls man
flecker das war aber hinterher gar nicht
der fall
und dann trinke ich das ganze mit einem
sehr starken trinkaus
nachdem der boden dann getränk wurde
können wir auch schon die füllung drauf
geben und hier gibt ihr einfach alles
auf die mitte komplett und dann müsst
ihr das ganze verstreichen
da aber der eckige butt rahmen zu groß
war und nicht auf die form gepasst hat
müsst ihr euch dann mit so einer
zeitkarte weiterhelfen
das geht aber auch relativ schnell und
einfach denn die creme ist der stand
fest und wenn ihr das dann schön glatt
verstrichen habt und die kanten auch
schön verstrichen habe dann kommt das
ganze für ca 20 minuten mini kühlschrank
vorbild an den deckel drauf geben wenn
ihr dann den weg geht raus getan habt
ihr ihn auch noch mal mit ausreichend
kakao und dann geht es auch schon weiter
mit dem kinde countries
[Musik]
und ich habe den boden auch nicht
zufällig 20 mal 20 zentimeter groß
gebacken den jetzt passen genau fünf
kinder countries auf jede seite
[Musik]
an dieser stelle befestige ich die torte
jetzt noch mal mit meinen beko band in
erster linie dient das jetzt dazu dass
die china kannte ich mich um fallen
dafür gibt es aber auch gleich einen
einfachen klick dann nach der schulzeit
werden wir dann auch ökogas brauch
machen ich zeig euch schon mal die
zubereitung ich habe mir 200 gramm voll
mit kuvertüre geschmolzen und gebe dazu
jetzt 80 gramm sahne ganz ganz wichtig
ist dass die sahne heißt oder warm
allerdings darf sie mich lauwarm sein
denn das ganze lässt sich ansonsten
überhaupt nicht verrühren und wenn ihr
das dann schön glatt gehört habt dann
ist es auch schon fertig die schoko
ganache wird dann auf die oberfläche der
torte gegeben und glatt verstrichen
[Musik]
und wenn ihr dann die ghanas so
verstreicht dass sie die kinder
countries alle berühren dann hält es die
coaches auch zusammen und sie fallen
euch nicht nur um jetzt geben wir auf
die noch flüssige ganache und cerealien
das sind 40 gramm die ich da noch darauf
gebe dass könnt ihr aber nach belieben
machen für einen optischen abschluss
nochmal geschmolzene kuvertüre darauf
verteilen und dann ist die torte auch
schon fertig und ihr müsst sie nicht
mehr kühlen sie sofort soll wir bereit
[Musik]
und das ist meine interpretation der
kinder country torte natürlich zeige ich
euch auch noch im anschluss damit ihr
doch boden kleben verhältnis geht es bei
dieser torte sehr wichtig dass wir viel
creme im gegensatz zu dem teig haben
damit wir auch nicht nur auf teig beißen
und die creme schmeckt meiner meinung
nach wie die original kinder kann für
spülung könnte sie auch einfach wohler
fühlen aus einer schüssel aber besser
ist es wenn ihr mit torte draus macht
und falls ihr sie nachmachen möchte dann
schießen wir noch gerne wieder über
instagram euro fotos darüber freue ich
mich sehr und ich sag bis zum nächsten
mal auf s kitchen